this is the untold story of babies and
what happens when you put a room full of
them together
beware discretion is advised this is a
baby basically a human but smaller and
always drunk
she has caught the eye of a boy baby he
has picked out a ball for her now
they're having a moment that will soon
be forgotten because they're babies
none of them are sure where they are
there's someone's birthday or something
oh it's for a photo shoot the world's
biggest baby photo shoot
seriously the dumb parents have enough
pictures of their kids paster the worst
am i right
what here is a baby being fed lemons by
his mother so he can see how sour it is
look how the mother is smiling while the
baby cries you know it's not actually
that bad outside the womb uh-oh here's
some new babies to join the fun watch
out this baby pooped himself and
couldn't care less this baby is trying
to connect with another baby
but he felt that relationship was moving
too fast and now she is alone this is
when she realized that Disney movies
were all lies this baby has found a
friend to cry with sometimes it helps to
have a friend wish I had a friend there
is a woman touching the babies and
taking their pictures the babies seem to
have no say in any of this out of
boredom these babies have started their
own Fight Club here's a baby trying to
escape the ball pit silly baby there is
no escape this prodigy is getting a head
start with snapchat has created a new
filter with her mouth and another baby
afraid of commitment that's a bad baby
bad babies get fed lemons there are so
many babies in the room now well finally
this must mean it's time to take the
picture say cheese little ones jeez
waiter or any of the babies look in the
camera what was the whole point of any
of this in any case we're gonna reward
them anyway here are some bubbles
soothing calming bubbles oh well I guess
it doesn't work for everyone now here's
a montage of babies falling